live talks in this session the first
talk is by Yang Liu who will talk about
specifying sums of norms
thanks venkat for the introduction um
I'm young I'm young I guess I'll just
write my name
and I just graduated from Stanford and
I'll after this workshop I'll be at the
IIs for a postdoc for about a year and a
half so
now let me talk about sparsifying sums
of norms
the specification problem in general is
the following
we have functions F1
functions on RD mapping to rb0
and let's define the sum f of x
1X Plus F and X
and the sparsification question is in
general can we reduce the number of
terms in the sum in some way while still
maintaining the value of the sum up to
some approximation factors so
formally we can ask
for this classification
once you find some weights W1 to WN
and someone a lot of them are going to
be zero that's kind of the goal these
weights
big weights and if we Define f tilde of
x to be W1 F1 X
plus w n f n x the goal is to ensure
that
f of x minus F tilde of X is in most
Epsilon times f of x or all X in r d
and the second property is that at most
um
some number
of W1 to WN are non-zero
I guess um in a lot of smartification
problems the question is what's the best
thing you can put here and very
optimistically the dream is something
like
Epsilon to the minus two times D and
then let's say some logarithmic factors
in D over Epsilon
so that's kind of the dream goal
so now
in general sparsification has led to or
like understanding the settings which
functions you can sparsify has led to a
lot of progress and fast algorithms for
convex optimization and graph Theory Etc
let me just give some examples
to uh yeah uh one very classical example
is when you have vectors A1 through a n
in Rd and the function f i of X is
defined as a i dot x squared
in that case
uh this is known as spectral
sparsification
and it's basically
akin to maintaining the
uh the form induced by The Matrix which
is uh less than just write it like x
equals A1 A1 transposable
you want to sparsify that sum that's
called the spectral specification
problem
I guess what I'm going to tell you about
is a result I've been working on
recently that ex that tries to
understand maybe in more generality what
functions you can sparsify or let's say
one version uh we can show a lot of
things but I'll just State one
particular version
forms of norms
so hopefully this is clear I'm going to
let f i of X be n i of X where n i is a
semi Norm
on RD
and then in this case the theorem is
that there exists weights W1
to WN
that make it a sparsifier
Delta X
W1 and 1X
plus W N N Sub n of x
and Epsilon sparsifier in other words
satisfies that condition over there with
the Epsilon and the number that are
non-zero is at most I guess Epsilon to
the minus two D then uh something like
log to the two point uh so
3.5 D over
okay so that's like uh so that's a
theorem okay
um I guess the reason this is
it's something that seems quite General
and uh in some sense generalizes this
because a i dot X is a norm
um obviously I would need to have like
squares here or something but you know
something like that
okay so that's the theorem statement uh
and it's quite General there's
applications for example to
sourcifying sums of symmetrics to
modular functions this is because you
can show that the lovaz extension of a
symmetric submodular function is indeed
a setting volume so for example you can
get things on that okay
Seminole means non-zero things can have
zero oh that's right yeah yeah
it's like it satisfies the triangle
inequality basically and scaling but
and uh I will just State the algorithm
and then I'll conclude in general for
sparsification all the algorithms take
the following form we will pick real
numbers P1 to PN that are at least zero
and then the way we construct the
sparsifier is we set I guess also
they're probably in
uh probably also at most one
the way you construct the sparsifier is
you said w i to be p i inverse with
probability
pi and zero otherwise
this way the sum there is is unbiased at
least the expectation of w i and I of X
is going to be an i of X so the sum is
unbiased but obviously you need to show
it holds for all X which is the
difficulty
so I guess I'm just going to State how
we choose the pixes and kind of just end
there so the way we choose the Pix is to
construct the sparse fire is we Define
the measure mu which is proportional to
e to the minus n of X where n is the sum
um and this is a law concave
distribution and then we use con and
then we set p i to be rho times the
expectation of x from mu of n i of X and
rho is going to be this like like an
over sampling parameter Epsilon to the
minus 2 log to the 3.5
um so yeah if you pick these pis defined
this way and you sample then you we can
show that it is a sparsified with high
probability
so I'm just going to conclude there
[Applause]
questions
yeah any connections to learning Russian
uh any any connections to learning or
regression good uh that's a good
question
um to answer that there's a lot of
regression problems uh for example
um let's consider the problem of LP Norm
regression I'm just going to write it
here the problem of LP Norm regression
is the following
it's um you want to minimize the sum
over I of the absolute value a i dot x
to the P right so if you want for
example a 1 plus Epsilon approximate
solution of this you would sparsify
um you would sparsify this where the
function f of I is this okay now that
will give you a one plus Epsilon which
is like a low accuracy solution it turns
out that if you want high accuracy
Solutions you need to sparsify not this
term but actually things that are more
complicated for example these things
that are like I don't know if you've
heard like Huber losses but they're
basically functions that go beyond this
and uh if you understand sparsification
for that then you can get fast
algorithms for high accuracy regression
one more question
can you compute those probabilities
efficiently
um so
because you can sample sample uh depends
on what efficiently means in polynomial
time yes but uh not much more efficient
than that like if you assume an access
to like an oracle for n of X then you
can get these probabilities well enough
to high accuracy
and it looks like this is equal to the
effect of resistance in the spectral's
classification case also equal to
[Music]
0.
good um so when and when like these when
this fi of X is the squared it equals
the effective resistance but I guess for
any other functions it will give I guess
different sampling probabilities which
also give a smart supplier factors but
they should be different from Lewis
weights yeah
okay so nothing maybe we can set up yeah
can you say anything when uh the domain
of these functions is not Rd or and they
say something like the hyper tube
um
so I just uh
can I say anything in that case so for
example as I was saying um this result
captures the case where like
uh F5 of X or symmetric some modular
functions which are naturally only
defined in the hyper queue but they have
an extension to Rd which is a semi Norm
so like for example you might attempt to
do things like that yeah
cool cool
obviously happy to take questions
[Applause]
foreign
also from Stanford who will tell us
about random graphs thresholds and
additive combinatorics
so um if I'm finishing up my PhD
I'll be here over the summer and then
next year
so today I hope to tell you about some
stories about various models of random
paths and recent progress in random
graphs have seen quite a few fruitful
connections to other surprising areas I
won't touch so much on the connection to
probability Theory and sarcastic
processes today where I'll focus a
little bit more on some interesting
connections to additive combinatorics so
let's start with the random graph models
that we are interested in so first we
have the classical model of edit
training random graphs so in this case
your edges will just be independent
bernoullis with probability p then we
will also convey the random Kelly graphs
and there are natural motivations for
this so to define a random Kelly graph
we would first fix an ambient Group G so
to us G is a arbitrary finite group and
the graph the Kelly graph is specified
by a generating set s which is a
symmetric subset of G and by symmetric I
just mean that if you have an element G
in s then G inverse also have to be in s
and then we would Define a graph where
we put an edge between two elements of
the group X and Y if x y inverse is an
element of the set s
okay this will define an undirected
graph and now if you want to define a
random Kelly graph you can just put
elements in the generating set as
independently with probability P subject
to the Symmetry condition and in that
case you would get this random Kelly
graph GP
okay so again as typical case of random
class we are interested in finding
structures in either the additionally
random graphs or these random Kaylee
craft lines otherwise we are usually
interested in monotone properties that
are defined on these families of running
cars so to give some motivation let me
revisit one of the first applications of
the random graph and that's two Ramses
Theory and in this case we are
interested in studying a distribution of
large independent sets or large Clicks
in random graph in the addition case
this is very easy
so just buy the vanilla first and second
movement method we can prove that let's
say in the dense case so when the
density p is equal to one half the
largest independent set and similarly
the largest click will have size about
two plus zero one times log base 2 of N
and in fact we know much more precisely
just based on the second moment method
for example this Independence number is
going to be typically just take on one
of two values and actually on just a
single value for most on for most values
of n
so let's see what would happen in the
random Kelly case and even and now we
see that we run seem to run into quite a
lot of trouble so even if we just want
to compute the first moment of the
number of independent sets in random
Kelly graph we see that we run into
quite non-trivial additive combinatorial
or group theoretic question and in
particular the question here is how to
count the number of subsets a of the
group G for which the product sets a
times a inverse have a small size and
it's not so clear how to do this
uh there are several nice works by Ben
green and then Ben green and Robert
Morris where they rely on additive
combinatorial arguments or harmonic
analysis to prove up to to get discounts
and in particular obtain the first
moment so they give some bounce on the
size of independent sets in random Kelly
graph but because it rely heavily on the
community additive combinatorial inputs
it only works for very special groups
such as F2 to the N or the cyclic group
at the end
and even just in these cases we already
see that the answer can depend quite
heavily on the group structure so in VN
The Click or Independence number will be
similar to the addition random graph but
in F2 to the end the size of the largest
click and independent set is
asymptotically larger so it's about
order lock the size of the group Times
log clock the size of the group
so we're trying to move beyond the case
of this very special nice a billion
group and so we try to fix some more
robust combinatorial argument and in
upcoming work with David Collins Jacob
Fox and lyanna Premier we can prove that
indeed the independence and click number
of a random calligraph of density one
half in an arbitrary Group G not
necessarily a billion it's always
bounded or both by log size of G Times
log size of G and as we mentioned before
this is actually tight for example for
any finite field Vector space although a
few of mounted characteristics
and as I mentioned our argument avoids
using sophisticated additive combinatory
so it's a purely probabilistic argument
and just a purely combinatorial so in
particular the argument also vice versa
implies strong strong calories on the
word of additive combinatory so it
implies strong bound on cows of sets
with small product set in general groups
and
um the argument actually also works for
a family of graph that are much more
General than just a random Kelly graph
book we call this entangled graph and
they actually have also appeared before
and so here there are several
interesting questions to ask so well for
a general Group G we saw that we may not
be able to hope that the random graph
would be Ramsay and by being Ramsey
meaning that it have Independence and
click number Big Goal of block the size
of the group and
um we are so we may be interested in
seeing how to remove this log block
factor and we have partial progress on
on this um in several cases so we can
define a tweak of the random model but
we even over find a few Vector spaces we
can define a random Kelly graph not a
uniformly random Kelly graph that
satisfy the Ramsay property so it has
small Independence and independent set
and clicks and furthermore so through
through this argument we can construct
self-complementary Ramsey graph which
answers some questions along uh that was
posed based on some connection between
self-complementary around the graph to
dual Source coding and repeated
Communications and the other motivation
here is on a launch conjecture who along
conjectures that in every Group G there
is a Ramsay calligraph with small click
and Independence number and we can prove
a launch conjecture for a wide a wide
range of group although not all of the
groups yet so one of the last important
open cases would be the case of over F2
to the end
okay so so far the entire discussion is
just about clicks and I want to and
usually in random graph you want to
study much more General things I just
click so let's just take a little bit of
a broader view now so in random graph we
usually try to study thresholds and
given you know a desired family of
structures like clicks or Cycles we the
threshold is the transition point at
which the random graph transitions from
unlikely containing to likely containing
that structure and uh this recent result
I have with Jin Jin young park building
on previous beautiful breakthroughs on
the sunflower conjecture fractional
conjecture and also our joint work on
Telegraph selected process conjecture
essentially gives you a reduction
between the probabilistic task of
estimating the threshold to a
combinatorial task of estimating the
expectation pressure which I will not
Define but it is kind of a linear
program or in other words kind of a
deterministic but complex combinatorial
object so well this theorem is if if
it's nice but the point of having this
theorem is that we try to we want to be
able to apply it but then we realize
that out of just a few highly
specialized on the challenging cases
estimating the expectation threshold is
actually can be can be very challenging
towards this task I'll just mention here
uh two of my recent work with my
co-authors that that kind of show that
this task can be quite interesting in
itself and it needs draws on quite a lot
of tools in combinatorics and
theoretical computer science and
algorithmic ideas
uh but there are also many other recent
Works along this line by other respected
researchers and
um and in fact if we revisit our
previous discussion of random Kelly
graph we see that well this theorem
actually holds much more generally not
just two random graphs but also to
General monotone Boolean functions so in
particular it also holds for the random
calligraph but the main difficulty in
the Kelly case is that we actually don't
have a very good technique of
understanding the expectation threshold
for the family of random Kelly graph so
with that let me end with some
interesting things that we can try to do
next so for example a general we can try
to build more General and robust
techniques for estimating expectation
thresholds but specifically to random
Kelly graph we may also try to have a
much more General toolbox to understand
thresholds and properties of sparse
random Kelly graphs and I haven't
mentioned this but in quite a lot of
basic properties like in the large
independencies or containment of
hamiltonian Cycles the Kelly case have
been mostly attacked by going through
the spectral method or by using the
spectral band so in other words so far
we are finding structures in random
Telegraph just by using the fact that
they are pretty good spectral expanders
but this will lead to quite some optimal
balance and it's it's a quite an
interesting task but also challenging to
try to use fully the randomness of these
random Kelly models and go beyond the
battles that are given by the the
spectral techniques okay thank you
any questions probably
so see your result it works for any
group but I guess I found that
surprising because sometimes there's
groups which are very different from
trying to build back to the space like
if you have a quasi random group or
something so do you have an explanation
for this for why they should be the same
even though the groups tend to have very
different apps yeah so the bound that we
prove here is just an up about on the
quick and Independence number so this up
about turns out to be tight for
financial records basis but most of the
time it will not be tight so for most
groups you expect that that this is
actually just we go of Lucky so like in
the case of secret group
Independence number will be so super
like a highly known a billion group
would be closer to one yeah so one would
expect that is
more likely around
I'll tell you that it roughly comes from
the fact that there are many many
subgroups like let's say you know find a
few Vector spaces and so unless your
group have this range property that
there's a holds on the subgroup at the
appropriate size then the answer will
not suffer from this additional factors
okay
so I had a quick question is do you
think any of these would be easier to
re-randomize than GA and one half
because I mean explicit constructions of
Ramsay graphs so it's been a major Focus
right so they they certainly use a lot
less uh Randomness or the random candy
model that that's only linear setup that
come out of Randomness but it's not
clear at all if it's easy to to just
fully you know
yeah
that was one of the first Motors
motivation for for us looking at
different
right so yeah for the question thank you
we'll close off the program with three
talks on influences in Boolean functions
and created topics so the first of those
will be given by macron
on something about block multi-linear
functions
[Music]
so I tried to use charity to write
control
the sense of humor is worse than mine so
you'll have to suffer
okay
so in the following the type I mean this
event so they're supposed to meet me so
this is who I am I've been a postdoc
here for the last almost two years so if
you want any recommendations about any
coffee shops breweries hikes or if
you're craving for danger just talk to
me
and my time here is coming to an end I'm
moving to UFO and then summer
and broadly I'm sort of interested in
complexity different aspects
and recently I've been thinking a lot
about Quantum complexities uh uh also
worked on optimization and stochastic
processes
so
yes I'm supposed to give a talk so let
me tell you a short story about Olympics
and decision trees uh in the next five
minutes
so
let's meet the first protagonist of the
story which is a polynomial
consider multivariate polynomials in and
variables
and we'll assume that the polymer is
like multilinear so there are no squares
or higher
hours of any monomial
and we're interested in the values of
this polynomial on the vertices of the
hypercube on all plus minus 1 to the end
points
and for this talk we'll assume that
polynomial is bounded so it takes values
between 0 and 1 and different values on
different points of the cube
so
I guess that's the first protagonist
team protagonist
which is a decision tree probably lives
in a different Universe on this
partition
uh so I mean here you query like a bit
and depending on the value of the bit
you could choose another bit to query so
this gives you algorithm to compute the
value of a function on any polynomial
and when you reach a leaf of this
decision tree you just output whatever
number is written there and
a number written is between 0 and 1.
so if this decision tree has depth d
it should be very easy to see that you
know you can write whatever function
this computes as a polynomial of degree
D just by you know doing some sort of
recursion
and the main question that I've been
thinking about for the last few years
is when you go the other way
if you have a degree deep element that
is bounded on the hypercube
can you construct a decision tree for it
that's uh okay maybe allow you to blow
up the size by a little bit
and I will also allow you to error err
on some fraction of the points it can be
wrong on few fraction of the points if
you want or you can be
closing let's say L2 or something so
that's the question seems very basic but
we don't know much about it
so
so let's look at very simple case so
suppose the polynomial on most points of
the hypercube is close to some constant
value here let's say it's close to one
half takes uh and maybe there are a few
points where it's very far away like
zero
in this case there's a very simple
decision tree for it you just output one
half at the leaf so it's very easy to
construct a decision tree for this case
what happens if the polynomial is
varying a lot so sometimes to take value
zero sometimes takes very large values
all over the cube so can you build that
uh decision tree for it
and this is where this conjecture of
Anderson and minus comes in it's a sort
of very well known conjecture probably
people here know more about it than I do
so this basically says that there is
some coordinate Direction
so some access parallel Direction along
which the derivative of this polynomial
is very large on average meaning that if
you go from left to right in this
picture the value of the polynomial
changes a lot on average
okay changes by 1 over polynomial of a
degree
so if you have
this conjecture is true if there is
always such a uh direct coordinate
direction for every
polynomial that is bounded and you can
very easily construct a decision Tree by
doing some sort of some sort of
recursion so I mean if you query this
variable you split the cube into two
parts
and I mean it's easy fairly easy to show
that each time you do this the problem
is the variance of the polynomial goes
down it starts varying less and less and
at some point here back in the previous
case where the polynomial is basically
constant so and since the influence is
one over quality you only need to make
quality queries basically
let me continue so one of the very
interesting special case or sort of
a case that has an interesting
application is when this polynomial
comes from a Quantum query algorithm so
such algorithms instead of querying bits
they can query input bits in a
superposition
and uh
for now you don't need to know much
about them but if you can prove there is
a decision tree for even such
polynomials it will give you like a
classical way to simulate any Quantum
algorithm that uh that's efficient on
essentially most inputs that's a very
interesting open problem it's been
studied for a while
yes I messed up the animations here so
this should come later but uh
so in a recent work we studied like uh
special case so let's look at the
polynomial with sort of every monomial
contains variables one variable X
another variable y another variable of
the form Z so the variables are
partitioned basically and each monomial
is built out of such variables so even
if
you have such polynomials again this
conjecture is wide open we don't know
much about it although there is some
work
and what we looked at in the recent work
this very nice observation that was made
by Royal Challengers and paluzelos it
says that if this polynomial actually
comes from a Quantum algorithm
it's not just bound into the hypercube
but it has a
uh much more nicer property that is the
completely bounded
let me just tell you on a high level
what it means
it means that if you view this
polynomial as a matrix polynomial your
X1 Y2 Z3 are just matrices now of some
arbitrary large dimension
and if you plug in matrices with
operator Norm Atmos one
then the operator Norm of this Matrix
polynomial uh as Matrix Still Remains at
most one okay so if you plug in scalars
this is exactly and between plus minus
one this is exactly the value of the
polynomial the hypercube but now you're
allowed to plug in a matrices of large
and larger dimensions
come out of quantum algorithms do they
have to be projections
uh I mean there can be unitaries
operator Norm at most one
yeah what about things like they don't
commute so
I mean okay so that's why I wrote the
column in this form X1 y1 Z3 where
everything orders basically fixed and
there
if it's a normal polynomial then I think
you need to Define what is
so in a recent work we sort of showed
that in this case this conjecture is
true and the coolest part for me about
that this relies on connections was
called non-commutative probability or
pre-proplicatory
algebra so it's a very nice very cool
field
and this gives you a way to classically
simulate some kind of counter value
okay
so I think that's more or less it uh
I wanted to have like this animation
like that and then end of a movie with a
credit scroll but my animation skills
are you know
strong enough for that but this wouldn't
be possible without all these wonderful
works and wonderful ideas so I guess
yeah I have to give Mercury issue so
thank you
if there are more questions
yeah so if instead of completely bounded
you say it's bounded on matrices of
Dimension up to some end you get some
bound depending on it ah we don't know
how to prove that but I would really
like to prove we could plug in two by
two great results or let's say in
complex numbers
and improve something but we don't know
how to prove so for this proof we really
plug-in matrices like incident you take
N2 infinity and then it becomes like
free operators and some C style algebra
so
hello
but okay yeah and you hear about this
quality right it was e to the ministry
that would just followed by KDL okay E2
minus V is not it's not okay
so it's a bounded function it's not a
Boolean function
so the museum is like you mentioned uh
it doesn't apply the Earth uh only for
these especially completely honorable
moments of this form
okay
so one question is we now know the
quantum to uh you know randomize or
deterministic query complexity the
relations right the polynomial relations
so so how does errorism still fit in
yeah and those are like you want to be
really correct in all points and if you
ignore some fractional points for
instance
we don't know
any other questions
thank you
oh and uh and to make a public service
fellows happy hour we should show up
because it's a lot of fun and I guess
thanks for the plug
thank you
[Music]
I don't know
okay so we continue uh more stuff on
influence will tell us about I guess
this theorem with which one of the
coolest names in my opinion he came to
work
okay so uh in this talk I'm I want to
like share you with this result event
over here it's over it's actually a as
already told it's about the influences
on Boolean functions
okay so uh
maybe let me just uh review some basic
uh definitions the first here we are
interested in Boolean functions
and the influences for
a variable X I with respect to this
function is just the probability that
you flip the value of a function by
flipping your input x i
on a uniformly random input X and the
max influence of this function is just
the maximum over all the individual
influences
okay so let's look at some examples uh
it's basic but it's related for our
results so maybe it's good to look at
few examples the first one is the
majority function
the majority function just outputs the
majority bit
Hardware inputs and its Max influence is
order of one square one over square root
of n
and this is a
because that if your input is sensitive
meaning that by by flipping this bit you
flip the value of a function it has to
be the case that on your input there are
about equal number of zeros and ones
right and on a random input this event
happens with probability like one over
square root of N and conditioning on
this event you know you have like the a
constant fraction of the majority bit
which you can put so that's why the
major the majority function has Maxine
plus one over square root of it
okay that's the first example and the
second example is the tribes function
adapts to ac0
circuits and the parameters are chosen
so that it outputs
0 and 1 with approximately equal
probability in particular you are set
depending for the end function as n over
log n and depending to the or function
as about login
and the max influence for the tribes
function is log n over n
uh also like it's very easy to check why
this is the case let's just consider the
case where we have an input that outputs
zero
so it can be calculated that with a
constant probability
there will be a special or Gadget
that outputs zero and all the other or
Gadget outputs will and in this case the
input of the or to this or Gadget will
be sensitive you can flip them to flip
the value of your function and the other
inputs you can't fully they are not
sensitive so there because defending to
the or gate is about login so uh the max
influence of tribes function is log n
over n
so uh for both these functions their Max
influence is like polynomial small
and the output like there and one with
about equal probability and that's the
kind of functions that we are being
interested
although it may be a little bit uh weird
if you haven't encountered such
functions before
but they actually appeared very
naturally in many applications like uh
the first application is the social
Choice Theory
which is also like the It N over here
it's over uh name comes from
so for example uh maybe you know after
uh after this meeting and during the
weekends we want to uh we want to hang
out with our friends and we want to
decide whether we uh stay at home
playing some games or enjoy some outdoor
activities
and you really want to handle together
with your friends so you need to make a
decision
so maybe uh you will take the majority
vote
or like you can use some other more
complicated function to aggregate your
decisions uh like how we uh elect the
president
but normally we always want
some kind of Criterion on how we
actually aggregate this decision so we
don't want there is a single person that
can kind of decide what to what's the
outcome without without caring about the
other people's opinions
so max influences kind of captures this
notion
and well we are computer scientists so
more familiar things to us is the
harness of approximations so we know the
dictatorship test
[Music]
and then third motivation maybe comes
from this uh invariance principle
phenomenon yes so it it Loosely speaking
it says that if for your function there
is no input bit that
uh has a large influences then you can
actually replace this bit if you
consider it as a random uh Boolean
variable then replace it with a random
gaussian variable and the output
Behavior will be uh similar and uh most
the probably the most uh like familiar
example for us is the Central limit
theorem when we add up a bunch of uh
plus one minus one
variables then it's it's like to add up
some gaussian variables
okay
so another notion that is probably very
familiar to all of us is the random
restriction
so we just want to say fix a p fraction
of random variables by designing a
uniform random values
okay so that's like the setup uh now I
can really actually tell tell you what
is about this it then over to it's over
theorem
so in this work we we actually so it's
we actually strengthened we are we
obtained an optimal version of this
theorem so
in particular we show that if we have a
function of that has more influences and
it's kind of balanced it outputs uh zero
and one with approximately same
probability
then
we can set the lie probability to be
like 1 over log one over the max
influence think about majority or the
drive function that is you keep only one
over log n fraction of the inputs alive
then with high probability that your
function is not going to be a constant
function
that's the result maybe let me make some
remarks about this result
so uh this is optimal with respect to
DLI probability in because just consider
the tribe's function it's a dabs 2 ac0
circuits so by has to switch Lemma if
you restrict one over log n fraction
will be your inputs then it's going to
be a constant function
so uh that's the first part the second
part is like here
I just write it as being non-constant
but you can actually have uh yes more
a quantitative version like uh bound
it's very how the variance changes under
the random restriction so we got some
bump for that and it it will be optimal
with respect to the majority function
you can analyze what happens for the
majority function and the bound where
the two bounds were matched
uh yeah
so uh
so maybe more remarks so the the
conjecture was first the conjecture is
just about uh
suppose we keep like only cons we just
restrict only a constant fraction of
the inputs then whether the remaining
function is non-constant
um
and of course we got something much much
stronger
and also uh the original version was
first proved by Melissa O'Donnell and uh
let's give it using various prints our
approach is more like Pathways
stochastic analysis
okay and also like older uh clips and
more so they obtain the different
approach that's very nice I think
okay uh yeah so that's it it's over
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
any questions to open this question
again saying it's not fully over
original proof like went through proxy
analysis of the noise operator do you
guys directly analyze restrictions or do
you also go through something no we oh
okay we we go through the restrictions
we we directly announced this analyze
the restrictions yes but I mean like uh
restrictions you can also view it as a
noise operator if you want yeah
other questions
okay
[Applause]
okay for our final Talk of the morning
we'll have SDK element tell us about
another famous conjecture in Boolean
function analysis the Fourier entropy
thank you
hi everyone so I thought that you should
meet me and to hear about it but you
already hear about the influences so I
will tell you a little bit about myself
just because I have this slide and like
uh Lauren did but okay so I'm doing now
a postdoc and Boston Boston University
and MIT this is part of Ford C program
and I have many hosts you can read the
names by yourself uh last year I think
it was lucky in Israel
hosted by Gil kalai and
publish the paper without Gill with
other people about a lot degree testing
over the reals which is very interesting
but I'm not going to tell you anything
about it today
um
last year I also visited here for the
program of causality and I really like
to be here so I came again
and I also contributed to the
fraction of Freeman and theoretical
computer science bringing my new
daughter that today she has a birthday
she's one year old
her name Annette
and previously I finished my PhD that
actually
it felt like the previous talk was about
the introduction for my PhD
so summer so I'm going to skip what is
Boolean functions and
the same Cube that already appeared
there
and
I just like to say it like uh
to coloring and then we have the
influential edges which we already
talked about them just to see them here
so the influential just went from two
different values
and the total influence defined to be
just the number of all of these
influential edges up to some
normalization
and this is very important uh parameter
of Boolean functions and if it's small
we are very interested in what the
structure of this if it's large we're
also interested but we don't notice
anything
um
essentially and uh the
famous first result I think I think that
established the Fourier analysis is the
KKL check that there is a one variable
with none trivial influence
um so we need the
the individual influences which we just
look for some direction and see how many
influential just we have in this
direction and the total influence is
just the sum of all the influences and
then we can rephrase KKL as
there is some variables and Direction
with
non-trivial or uh
individual influence which is at least
exponentially in the total inference you
can see that if this total influence is
much smaller than login then this is not
reveal
um
okay and then came the
foreign
uh total influence is small then the
function is
can is actually very close to sparse
function
um
and then
thanks to collaboration with norm and
others reproved
something very close to the Fourier
entropy entrance conjecture which shows
instead of concentrating on to to the
influence we have here the other logo
and this implies
many things sharp threshold and others
and one thing that I want to mention
today is that functions with small
influence are now can be agnostically
learnable
in uh very fast so if we can think about
okay
[Music]
as login over log logins and we have
polynomial time agnostic
learning
um
it's about the proof so in the proof
resource it's actually combined from
correlation inequalities I would say in
a minute what is it
and it starts with proving the KKL
theorem in a very basic proof and just
improve it
um when we apply random restrictions
uh
and I would say what is it so
for correlation in qualities we have
we need the fact that every function has
unique representation for yeah
for your presentation and the degree is
the Fourier degree reach the maximal
degree
um
what do you think about it and why are
you interested in nor degree functions
or one thing we can see that functions
with small total influence actually
close to small degree and we know
something about low degree functions
even not a lot
um
actually we know some things about uh
Boolean functions with small degrees or
at least we know the hypercontractivity
which is
uh appears in many proofs
and what is the correlations or just
the inner product between two functions
is a correlation between them and this
defines also as to normal I'm not sure
why I say this but
um
okay so the first Lema is
something quite general not really
um so we have two functions one of them
is Boolean the other one is not
necessarily Boolean but
of law degree and we want to say that if
the influences are bounded we actually
can take this Delta to be just the max
inference
that we have we saw then their
correlation is bounded some exponential
in the end
the max influence and something that
called cross total inference which is
just as the total inference of some
function but we use the two functions
so the proof is easy but are not sure
today
and this actually implies the KKL sorry
it's quite easy to see that if we take
just D to B twice the total influence or
one over Epsilon and G to be just the
truncated f up to D and we take the now
the correlation between F and it's
truncated uh
degree then
using this bound we just get the KKL so
this is just the first step
and now the question is
can we do better and the answer is yes
otherwise we won't have to say anything
of this
um
and
the way to do better is to refine a bit
analysis using the sizes of the
influencers
is also generalize the influences and
the main tool is to reduce the degree
using random restrictions and we do it
repeatedly until we get a good result
and we don't know how to continue to get
the law to get rid of the log
and I will talk more about it on the
bootcamp so if you're interested your
you're invited on Monday
um
I have more things yeah okay so I'll
just talk a bit about other questions
that I work about
um if someone interested to know what
they do then talk to me so another thing
that I'm interested in are testing
property testing and estimation of
properties of Boolean functions and
specifically complexities that might
that results might imply explainable
machine learning and
another regime is delegating queries to
untrusted sources
they were in a way to improve sublinear
algorithms and make them
much faster using
powerful
may be interested
the server
and law degree testing in various
settings
is very interesting and also Boolean and
drills
and thank you
[Applause]
any questions
[Music]
okay if you have questions later just I
have a quick question so KKL is usually
stated slightly differently like there's
a login by n influential thing this is
equivalent to that form yeah it's
actually implied from this form what
they they proved this I see this implies
the other yeah
yes why should we care about the Fourier
entropy influence conjecture it doesn't
have any applications
in terms of applications
why should I assign send some some
people we care about ask the question
but what did I care about
you think about it yourself
I don't know why you do
I think that yeah I am interested in
you later
[Laughter]
yeah
total influence of God focus is at least
and then you get the shop shopping
I mean it's seen people have some
learning application too this agnostic
learning but that you're able to get
anyway bypassing the full conjecture is
that what you said the agnostic learning
of functions with low total influence
anybody
I mean
it doesn't matter
okay okay but this almost gets there
bypassing the full conjunction DNA
any other questions
if not thank you very much St and uh
indeed all the speakers of the this
morning for uh
and thanks to the audience for coming
and making the event a success and that
concludes uh this morning's program and
just a reminder for those who are part
of the analysis and TCS summer program
there is an orientation this afternoon
starting at 2 p.m
um I guess in the room on the other side
116.
okay thank you and have a great summer